California governor Gavin Newsome taken
a swing at Republicans while discussing
his States problems right now growing
concerns that California is reverting
back to its old ways after spending
Millions to clean up rampant
homelessness and open air drug markets
for the Apex Summit the Golden State
Governor taking to Liberal late night TV
and blaming the GOP for amplifying the
quality of life issues they've been on a
doom Loop about San Francisco ever since
Nancy close he became speaker California
has outperformed the American economy
it's the tenpole of American Recovery
and its values are a stark contrast
difference of daylight and darkness
between the Republican party they have
to focus on our failures in order for
them to be right San frco is a special
place uh it is a unique and special
place incredibly resilient and
vibrant and sounds like someone's
looking for a rematch after the big red
versus blue State debate Newsome taking
some shots at Florida's Ronda
santis I'm not running for president
United States Ronda santis apparently
still is i' I've developed a lot of
animus towards him because of his animus
towards all of you um you know this
guy's out there scapegoating vulnerable
communities uh he's attacking uh
minorities attacking women for me it's
not anti-woke what he really means is
anti-black he's out there censoring
historic facts he's rewriting history uh
he was out there you know he eliminated
AP African-American studies he said
slavery was some some Workforce
Development program and he doubled down
on that so for me it's a very serious
moment where I just felt it was
important to blow back against that
against that narrative a lot of finger
pointing coming from Newsome as
California grapples with major issues of
its own this year San Francisco
recording the highest number of
overdoses in the city's History Michael
shellenberger calling out California for
exacerbating the homeless crisis with
what he says is bad
policy you have we pay the highest taxes
in the entire country in California with
plenty of resources in fact all of the
spending is a reason we have these
problems they subsidizing addiction they
literally pay people to be homeless in
San Francisco and that's the underlying
problem to it and that there's no
discipline there's no law enforcement
and there's no mandating of the
treatment that people with mental
illness and drug addiction need in order
to get into recovery yeah okay uh
kellyan let's start here he says that
the governor does that California is the
Temple of the American recovery but you
know the the hundreds of thousands of
people who've left in the last couple
years don't seem to agree no
750,000 people have left California the
last two years 352 businesses in the
last four years that is not a
coincidence that's causation bad policy
high taxes homelessness you are tripping
over people and their natural discharge
as you try to make your way to school or
to work or places of worship and uh
other man-made problems for Gavin nuum
Shannon the light rail that he said he
was going to abandon he turned changed
his mind on that now is pumping billions
more into it it's not going to work and
you mentioned San Francisco the fact is
Los Angeles also now has fenel
surpassing meth as the number one crisis
in drug overdose death Oakland is
completely destroyed so this isn't a
fantasy or concoction of the quote
rightwing we know that the left is
failing in our major cities including
all across gavs California because we
have two eyes and two ears it's very
simple one thing I want to say you can't
blame Republicans when the eight top
office holders in the state of
California are all elected Democrats
when Democrats control if you added up
the Senate and the assembly together 96
seats to about 26 seats Democrat
Republican he owns all of this and all
of the great things we love about
California the weather the ocean the
beaches the mountain has nothing to do
with Gavin Newsome and the Democrats all
the things we don't like about
California they have put at our
footsteps I think abum should say mirror
mirror on the wall who's got the most
homeless of them all and Narcissus the
governor uh will find the answer very
plain and clear well I thought it was
interesting that he said with the right
coming after him he says they have to
focus on our failures in order for them
to be right but Greg that seems to admit
they do have
failures first I think it's really
unfair of Kelly Anne to wear that outfit
because there are like 15 jokes I want
to say but I'm not going to I can't
because I don't know her well enough I'm
I'm I'm afraid of Kelly an Conway do
what it will be Wonder wa wait am I
going to have to call HR superimpose
Gavin's head on
this I would say beetle juu is looking
for his jacket but anyway a I'm joking
look a couple of things or a lot a lot
of things first of all he calls San
Francisco resilient you don't describe a
place that's go doing really well as
resilient a a very you you describe a
person who's undergoing serious health
problems as they're really resilient so
this place is Going Through Hell hence
he calls it resilient he brought up race
so you that opens the door to his
policies which are anti-black
anti-female anti-asian because all three
of them are victims of his policies you
know at least at Sis's policies are
about lifting all boats not sinking all
of them however what is his point is
irrelevant politicians point to each
other's failures all the time left and
right but that doesn't negate the
failures we're going to talk about it
later in the show California is now
going to be drinking water made out of
feces okay that's not that's not a
successful State Newsome's reasoning is
that it's like blaming the guy who calls
the fire department to put out a fire
for the actual fire itself his reasoning
would blame anyone for making a 911 call
to report a crime for simply calling out
of concern and saying something he would
prefer that you do not say something
remain silent lie back and enjoy it you
know I was born and raised in California
it's not a political thing for me it's a
tragedy to see what's happening to the C
to the state and in effect to the
country I would like to help I'm not
there just to point fingers I saw
firsthand experience here in NYC of the
crime wave uh we pointed this out on the
show I don't know three years ago we
were the canary in the coal mine here on
the five we were mocked by people on the
on CNN who are no longer employed was
that our fault for calling this out we
were called hysterics uh for pleading
with Democrats to do something if they
had listened years ago they would have
been Heroes and we would have been happy
for them and that's that's another Point
here you know Republicans actually do
want to help they're not just pointing
fingers right the weird thing about
conservatives is they'll pull over and
help fix your car or change a flat even
if you got a Biden Harris sticker on it
it's part of being for small government
you know relying on your on your
neighbors and individuals the modotto
motto of people on the right is we're
here to help not the government even if
you hate us but for some reason it's
never reciprocated because they see it
through the lens of politics oh they're
only coming after us because it's
political no we actually do care about
the fentol poisonings because we've been
talking about it for years we've been
talking about the drug addiction the
homelessness and the crime wave because
we care it's not a political thing for
us even if it is for you well and listen
if you do or don't like his policies you
talk about smaller government he's going
to have it whether he wants it or not
because now the governor is talking
about having to make major Cuts because
this this huge deficit you have people
leaving you have businesses leaving so
you're going to have a tax base that's
different um but will he says
Republicans are making their failures
sort of these Democrats that is an
avatar for what's wrong in the world it
reminds me the Chicago mayor who said
something recently too like it's the
right wing that's making us look bad
first I want to say Greg I think you can
can sleep soundly and safely I think
that the amount of incoming that has
come the way of kellyanne Conway a
little bit of ribbing over her jacket
probably didn't even Dent the surface
much l leave if I were to find out she
were sensitive about her jacket I would
requestion my total understanding of
reality for supporting the Philadelphia
Eagles tonight that is not what's
happening and now I am senstive as a
Cowboy fan America's team what I would
say about um Gavin Newsome is it is
incredible that he has become the face
of the Democrat Party because he is a
self-evident failure everything about
that state is on its face a failed State
and I could go through and I don't need
to because you really only need the one
one condemnation the one observation
that kellyanne and you Shan have point
out is that people are fleeing the state
in Thomas Jefferson's little
Laboratories of democracy that's the
biggest indictment that you can receive
I'm out all he has left the only thing
he has to recommend him I guess is that
he's a face jock and secondarily that he
is he's once again pulled out the knife
of racism homophobia vulnerable
communities he says Ron DeSantis isn't
anti-woke he's anti-black last time I
was on the five was right after the
DeSantis U Nome debate and I said we
should be worried about Nome because he
is a very effective liar but if he wants
to lie about the nature of America and
Rond desantis's moral soul I think he's
pulled out a knife that's dull I think
America is done with everyone who
disagrees with you is a racist that
knife has no Edge and he's going to have
to come up with some better lies if he's
going to be the face of Democrats well
Jessica a lot of people think he is
going to be the face of Democrats like
is in maybe on the ticket for you guys
next year you mean in 2028 next year no
I mean in 2024 he says he's not running
but it a lot of folks think it looks an
awful lot like a shadow campaign I I
think that there was a lot more Merit to
that argument like 6 months ago remember
when he went to the White House on a day
when Joe Biden was out Etc and now
really has become one of the strongest
Biden Harris surrogates out there and I
think the fact that he took on that
debate with Ronda santis and stood up
there and
said you should be talking to Donald
Trump right you're standing here with me
someone who's not on the ticket and
he'll be on in 2028 I'm sure that he'll
get into the primary then um but I don't
think that he has an aspiration to do it
right now frankly I think that having
just come out of Co and the scenes that
we see that California is not going to
be ready it's not the best laboratory to
go out and run a presidential campaign
on at this particular moment it doesn't
mean that there haven't been strides in
the right direction we see pictures of
homeless people all the time the
homeless rates are down in California
though 10% of the jobs that were gained
just last month in the US came from
California and he's making a very valid
point Republicans and Greg you might be
right that the average Republican is
desperate to change my tire and I would
welcome it if I get a flat because I
don't know what to do under the
circumstances but Ron Santa stood up
there and held a big poop map right and
didn't want to talk about the fact that
Jacksonville has a 67% higher murder
rate than San Francisco right he doesn't
want to talk about the homelessness
problem in Tampa you talk about having
to step over people you got to do that
in Tampa too I I have seen no politician
of either party that stands up there and
wants to Olive Branch with the other
side and say you know what you're doing
this right especially in a debate or
when you have a friendly interview
you're going to take every opportunity
to pound the other guy and they're
clearly targeting to santis because if
it's not Trump he's quite formidable I
know Nikki hilly is pulling ahead of him
in the head-to-head um with Biden but
Rhonda santz pointing out that Florida
is not Utopia and that it might have a
few problems does not in any way forgive
the in apparently insurmountable and
gigantic problems of the entire State of
California from crime and homelessness
to yes the economy to their Co policies
the fact that Florida isn't perfect
doesn't forgive California but that's
your political bias again that you
framed it that way I said a 67% higher
murder you know how many murderers that
is that's not like four extra murders
there a lot of murders but if you're
looking at the overall health of
California 2o in addition to that you
have to you know tens of billions of
dollars in deficit and the budget is a
disaster I led with the Governor's in
charge right all the Democrats are in
charge of everything okay all right
Jessica is going to come back in the
next episode comment strong hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to sub
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else